ce mardi 22 novembre à Bois-d'Arcy c'est
jour de match la ville retransmet la
rencontre de l'équipe de France face à
l'Australie la commune n'a pas hésité à
programmer une soirée malgré les
polémiques autour de l'organisation de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar nous on veut
juste passer un moment festif évidemment
tout ce qui s'est passé au Qatar et les
conditions de l'attribution sont assez
compliquées il faut pas obérer les
problématiques de développement durable
et de traitement de tous ceux qui ont
travaillé à la construction de ces
stades mais là on est face à la
compétition face au sport et on a besoin
de moments de convivialité tous ensemble
et je suis content qu'il y a une grosse
centaine de personnes se soir pour un
premier match en plein hiver sur le
terrain la France se fait rapidement
surprendre par les Australiens 1 à 0
mais les Bleus réagissent égalisent et
passent devant 2-1 et supporters
présents dans cette salle de la Fabrique
exulte à la pose ils sont confiants
la France qui pousse et je pense qu'ils
vont marquer encore deux un ou deux buts
et je pense ça va passer faut juste bien
défendre en deuxième période la France
continue sur sa lancée arrive à inscrire
deux autres buts Mbappe Giroud font
bondir les supporters artisans de joie
4-1 ce sera le score final je pense que
l'équipe de France sont bien joué il y
avait pas mal de passes et je pense que
avec les nombreux blessés on pouvait pas
s'attendre à mieux l'attaque était
incroyable par contre la défense un peu
moins forte que ça mais du coup j'étais
surpris par le niveau de l'équipe de
France par rapport à ce que je pensais
je suis plutôt rassuré malgré tous les
forfaits que finalement on a quand même
une équipe encore solide et on a espoir
ouais j'espère qu'ils vont aller au
moins jusqu'en demi-finale avant de
penser au demi-finale la France jouera
son deuxième match de poule ce samedi 26
novembre à 16h Bois-d'Arcy retransmettra
à nouveau le match